wow
all right i can do this i kept twisting
until it started locking itself again
i love that so before people think that
i am
congratulating myself a little
preemptively
um i did check the kickstarter no i am
not fully funded yet but no
i don't think that i am um
celebrating prematurely because this is
a launch party
it's like when you launch a ship and you
bash the bottle of wine or whatever
against it
whether that ship floats or if it sinks
you still get to have
the celebration for the launch so even
if this ship
sinks and does not hit its goal i'm
still
gonna have sparkling water
very sparkling water
ah hey folks how's everybody doing
actually you know what i got to
reposition this thing
a little bit sorry
hate to do this to you i'm gonna
shift that there and
up a little that's better i think i'm
more centered now
yes you also aren't seeing as much of
the puppet which as much as i
enjoy him is he's a little unsettling
just standing there going
so best best to not have him uh
be overly visible but anyways
let's see where's the hull of the ship
for that water to be smashed off
um in my belly
ah that water is a worrying color
well you know we don't have great uh
filtration where i live
how's tricks and does it really need to
be a launch party
for sparkling water that's true
i could drink this regardless but you
know i
uh this was fun to pick up i haven't had
water this sparkling
in a while so you know it's nice
at least by itself
i've had this kind of sparkling water
mixed with things i doubt that sparkling
water yeah why would you doubt me did i
read that comment already i might have
read that comment already boy i'm off to
a good start
ah drink more water i plan
to oh so
yeah sorry i'm
still fine tuning and adjusting this and
i am just gonna be a little bit annoying
about it
and do that this yes
cool i think yes
um what do i think of the goonies uh
it's fun
i enjoyed it as a kid not sure how well
it holds up
uh what's the kickstarter the
kickstarter is for my
novel um dreams of fire and it's to help
fund uh illustrations because for some
reason i decided to make it like a light
novel and have
um illustrations across it so yeah
which character in your book do you like
the most and which was the most fun to
write
um the character who i
like the most is probably
um there's a character who
ah i'm trying to think of how best to
explain him because like
his name doesn't get dropped for a while
because he's
kind of paranoid and he doesn't want to
give out a lot of information
but he he comes into the story and he's
kind of mysterious
but the the more you get to know him you
get to learn him
learn about him he's just very closed
off but not like in the
cool and like i'm so dark and edgy and
no one can only like no it's not that
dude's got damage i like him a lot as
far as the most fun to write
towards the end of the book there is a
um
there's a character who's uh who's a
boat captain
he was a lot of fun like to the point
that i
i kind of wish i could have figured out
a way to bring him into the plot sooner
so that i could write more of him i
really enjoyed writing him
and his interactions with his crew
and a lot of that a lot of that stems
from the fact that
what i enjoy writing most is dialogue
it's what comes most naturally to me and
his dialogue was a lot of fun to write i
actually thought i'd miss the stream
tonight because i was at the pub
i mean staying at home being way too
productive
yes be sure you hydrate while you're
staying at home being productive
the goonies was made in my home state of
oregon very cool
how am i i am doing pretty well
all things considered which which i feel
like is the answer that like
you have to scale for covid whenever you
answer that question how are you doing
like
with everything going on i'm pretty good
so tell us the truth is that really just
water in that glass or are you drinking
something
with alky tonight how dare you
how dare you impugn my honor and imply
that this is anything other than
crisp clean sparkling slightly
suspiciously colored water
well i never
uh what surprised you most when writing
um
i was surprised how many things i was
able to tie into existing stuff that i
already had
or like how much groundwork i'd laid
ended up
providing solutions like i would find my
there's something that i did about
midway through the book just because i
thought it was cool
and then later in a situation that i
wrote later on i realized oh i could
bring back that thing
and it was funny because the first time
somebody wrote a finished traffic
they're like i really like how you set
that up and then pay it off later i'm
like
yeah that was totally what i planned to
do as opposed to just
magically realizing oh crap i actually
have a solution to this situation that i
already created
intending to reuse it it's like
that's part of the part of the fun uh
i think of writing is is
figuring out how to use what you've
already got in play
to complete the work
um because you know i
for me i don't get as much thrill like
thinking up something new to bring in
like
i like looking at the pieces and playing
going ooh
i know what i can do with this and
that's that's the most fun sort of
discovery part of the process for me
uh
didn't catch the kickstarter is about
illustrations do you have them but need
money to commission
basically so i have some illustrations
and you see examples of that in the
kickstarter pitch video
um actually did i hold on
did i actually get
the
link to the kickstarter on hit yes i did
no i didn't
did i no oh for god's sake give me a
second
it should be in the description and i
don't think it is
um so yeah the primary thing that the
kickstarter is funding
is illustrations i do have some already
so you can see examples
of what they are going to be like as far
as style
um goes but um
that is that is the main expense and i
only have like
i don't know seven done uh so far
so there's a lot more that i would like
to be able to do and it's also helping
fund
um stuff like getting a just a cover
professionally designed getting a
world map uh professionally done and uh
and and things like that so there uh
there is
all that sort of stuff um as well but
the primary thing that it is
funding is the uh the illustrations
and let me get back to where i was
dang thing hold on give me a second
come on here we go and i'm back um
because i've already got an editor who
i'm working with and i'm in the middle
of the editing process
so last time i ran a um
a kickstarter the editor was the main
thing that the kickstarter was funding
but in this case that's already
paid for
if you compare the book to another for
flavor
what would it be ah god
um i don't know because most of my main
influences weren't other books
um like tone and
world feel wise my go-to is final
fantasy vi
uh for overall vibe of the thing
uh will hamilton replace next to normal
as your favorite musical
no no it won't i do like hamilton quite
a bit though it's a lot of fun
um what are your thoughts on the
never-ending story
well i've never read the book um i've
only ever seen
the move actually i've seen the first
two movies there's three
and an animated series woof um
but i it's it is
dated in a lot of ways but i think it's
it's just got that very fervent
imagination that i
like from a lot of that era of
children's entertainment from the 80s
so i i do enjoy it um
there's some weird stuff that goes on
like not just like the normal sort of
oh this is weird and imaginative like
the
like the the guardian sphinxes at this
gate that atreide has to go
through have boobs and
he beats it by running
like really he was the first person to
ever think to run instead of saunter
okay like there's some weird stuff in
that movie but it's pretty good
i'm also enjoying some water and the
only problem is it tastes a little like
jack daniels and coke how strange
you may want to get your tap checked
that's not a reason to stop drinking it
though
have you got a chance to listen to the
new monsters old doctors big finish yet
no i don't have that one i do have a
number of big finish that i have yet to
get to
but i'm trying to catch up on um
commissions before i delve too much back
into big finish unless somebody wants to
commission me to do some big finish
that's always an option
evening i was just watching the batman
the animated series till i saw this was
going on oh
i am sorry to pull you away from that
because that is a good good
show but uh thank you for joining us
uh what were your inspirations for the
story or the idea of the book
i mean the thing is you need to realize
how long i've been working on this thing
so me trying to trace back my
inspirations
i i actually kind of can't because at
this point i've been working on the
thing to varying degrees for so
damn long that i couldn't possibly
you know reverse engineer backtrack most
of these because the first conception of
what would eventually become this book
i had when i was 20. that was
18 years ago
and um excuse me
and yeah i've been working on this for a
long time so a lot of things have
probably seeped in
over time um as as i've been working on
it
i didn't have like a primary ooh i want
it to be like
this sort of thing though i had a long
list of things i
didn't want it to be which is not
necessarily the best way to approach a
book
because or any project because you
should know what it's going to be
as opposed to just what it isn't but i
think in the process of
avoiding certain things i i managed to
find what it was
as i went through it i love when that
happens in my stories i've accidentally
given myself the solution to my scenario
makes me feel
like the doctor if i'm being honest oh
yeah oh totally
i finally finished angel i did enjoy it
but i have to disagree with you i think
buffy was the better show like i know
that most people don't agree with me
and the thing is a lot of it for me just
has to do with overall
trajectory as a series buffy had its ups
and downs
and i personally feel that each season
of angel was better than the last
yes even season four and season five is
phenomenal
so uh jurassic park or
jumanji jurassic park look the original
jumande
jumanji i've got nostalgia for but i
um it's it's just it's just kind of
there it's fine it's functional
oh let's see
i get that for what i'm working on at
the moment i find so much
uh comes out in writing uh since it's a
play it's mostly dialogue and
it's true how fun some people can be to
write yep oh i
missed the question somebody um
oh oh somebody asked how much i planned
not
not a ton i don't outline i do however
know how it's going to end
um and i have to because if i don't know
my final destination i lose steam
if i don't know where i'm going so it
i i don't sit down and outline every
major beat
um and i don't i don't like do family
tree because
i don't do that level of planning i know
where i'm going
i have an idea of certain things that i
want to hit along the way
but how i'm going to connect a to b to c
to d
i don't know i find that out as i go
um but i do have to know the the um
destination otherwise i i just will
never finish
do you play any instruments no when i
was in grade school i played the trumpet
oh well sorry actually technically i
played the cornet
but they put me in the trumpet section
because nobody plays a coronet
uh at that age it was uh it was my
grandfather's coronet
um because he played professionally so
yeah uh i
have not touched it in decades i'm sure
i would be terrible now
if i was lucky i could get some sound
out of it i don't remember the fingering
for anything anymore and that sounded
really dirty
i'm sorry it's what it's called
ah what if you were to do a sketch
in your doctor costume where you were
gener
what if you were to do a sketching your
doctor costume where you were to
regenerate from drinking too much water
the doctor has a hangover so bad they
regenerate
oh i kind of like that idea i'm not
gonna lie
but then there's uh the people that
feels genuinely uncomfortable to write
because they're awful
i don't i don't have any characters in
the book
that are people i don't like like even
the villains
i know why they're doing what they're
doing and i gave them what i feel are
understandable if not relatable
motivations so i didn't i didn't have
anyone to write who was just
an atrocious human being across the
board i have a lot of very flawed people
some of them are really flawed but like
i get why they are doing what they're
doing so i i that was not something that
i
uh ran into what actually is your
favorite musical my favorite musical is
a show called next to normal which
if you're not a theater nerd you might
not know it is a story about a family
coping with mental illness
fun
what are your thoughts on the fox and
the hound i have not watched that movie
in
ages i remember it being vaguely cute
it wasn't even one that i watched much
as a kid i think i even had it i didn't
watch it that much
kind of annoying how i thought i'd
created some nice costumes for some
characters
in a series i'm going to make only to
realize
they look like discount drusilla spike
look driscilla and spike themselves are
not
super original looks spike is basically
billy idol and drusilla is kind of your
standard vaguely victorian era carmilla
type
like you're allowed to recycle them they
were recycled when drew and spike did it
it's fine chill out
like that's that's kind of a big thing
like if you get hung up
on not being original
you're never going to get anything
written the the goal
should be to is to take familiar things
and reconfigure them and put them to use
in a way that is entertaining for people
but do not get hung up in the idea like
like
this is part of the reason that i
actually don't dwell too much on where
my
influences and my inspirations come from
because i know myself
and i know i am liable to fall into the
trap of once i
identify an influence i'll go oh god i
basically just did that
oh no now it's not original and like i
know intellectually that's
a stupid hang up to have and
counterproductive but it's still there
so yeah no if they look like drew and
spike so what
uh if you dock my pay can i get a copy
of the book early
we'll we'll talk offline joel
um just want to say that i am loving the
firescape podcast i will
now pop some bubbly enjoying you oh
thank you so much
um i i'm glad that folks are
are enjoying that oh hey steven um can
you talk about the method
about what mythologies inspired your
book okay so
the um fantastical elements are largely
celtic inspired so that's sort of
fairy lore because you have pixies and
red caps
and dry ads and sort of that
um that sort of celtic old british
mythology with a couple of exceptions
because i've also got a huldra which is
a scandinavian
um mythological beast um
i i had a lot of fun working with the
halter like not a lot of people know
about those and like i
all of these are tweaked in in small
ways
um to to accommodate what i wanted to do
with them
um a little bit but uh hopefully not in
a way that is
like why would you even call it that
hopefully i didn't take anything that
far
but uh those were sort of where i pulled
a lot of
uh inspiration from for the for the
background mythology just be
well largely just because that's the
stuff that i actually know a little bit
here's
tell anybody but i suck at research
i'm not good at it i i
i chalk it up to the adhd i have a hard
time sitting down and focusing and doing
real thorough proper research so what is
more useful for me is to pull from stuff
that i already haven't
have some kind of knowledge base on
because it's something i was already
inherently interested in
if i try and sit down for the purposes
of research i will burn out
um and so like on the occasions when i
do research even for a video like
it's actually hard for me
that's like difficult stuff um
although it was fun looking up um
you know lesser known uh fade creatures
and fairy stories
um you know to see if anything sort of
clicked and
inspired me to to do something that i
might not have done otherwise
world map how uh to avoid the oh it's
tolkien's map
don't worry about it come up with your
design
don't copy his geography like the thing
is
the only thing that i would worry about
versus tolkien is don't copy the
geography
and don't and you know avoid you know
the same um
sort of specific imagery but like the
general look of the map yes it's gonna
look like tolkien's map
they all do that's fine
i do that with themes uh the looking
back on my early writing
includes bits in my main collection i
see so much depression
and anxiety see that's funny because a
couple of years ago
sort of looking through stuff that i'd
written including an early draft of this
book
and short stories that i'd finished and
my and the play that i wrote and a bunch
of other stuff and i realized
single thing that i have ever written
is in some way about
things in flux and things in transition
and things falling in the middle
between two states of being
i cannot possibly imagine why that's a
theme that keeps popping up
in my work
you've been kidnapped but the last
person you saw on a tv show
is trying to rescue you who was rescuing
you oh what was the last thing i watched
i think
i think the last thing i watched was
firescape so
that means that the firescape crew would
be coming for me
yeah that was yeah that was the last
thing cause um
jesse and i recorded yesterday and i
haven't washed anything today
that is some bubbly water
uh
jurassic park well world has a new
animated series coming out on netflix
yeah i saw that
whatever javier i have a question about
the turf wars essay jk rowling
said she is interested in ms which is
twice as likely to be developed by both
cis and trans women as
cis men do you have an opinion no
no i do not
i'm not in the mood to have a jk rowling
opinion tonight
with all respect is it weird that i like
tomorrow never dies more than golden eye
yes
it's fine that's totally fine but yes
it's weird
uh what are your thoughts on child's
play from 1988 i've actually never seen
it
only um child's play movie i've seen is
bride of chucky
which was fun oh actually no i saw seed
of chucky but i barely remember that one
i liked bride better
i showed a sister your dragon in last
week's stream and
got a little jealous words of warning
she's on her way with malicious intent
i have a rack of weapons with which to
defend my dragon
don't try it what am i
in best reach of i always have the axe
bring it on or
you know don't okay
bang that against stuff that's always
that's that's a sign of sobriety
right uh
let's see where are we
whoop okay chad is chad is jumping on me
i'm catching up
i am a ways behind
so apologies on that
uh i might try and catch up i don't
think that's gonna happen tonight though
um we are we are very different all my
characters are flawed and are by far
atrocious human beings but i'm still
trying to make them likable
hey to each their own in terms of
approach
uh after
the omega omega verse essay from lindsey
ellis i've wondered
how much you dabble in fanfic reading or
writing past or present
uh none i've never gotten into fanfic
uh i couldn't get into reading it
because i'm too much of a nitpicker
um and i
it i never felt inspired to write it
and that's not like a source of shame
like there's nothing wrong with fan
fiction fan fiction is great
it's it's it's a good healthy thing for
a fan community to do i think
but it's just it's just never been my
jam
i have friends who wrote fanfic
i'm not going to name names because i i
don't know if any of them are
embarrassed by it but
yeah no no shade on fanfic
do you watch any shows on abc nbc cbs
the cw parks usa tbs comedy central hbo
et cetera
so you'd the only currently airing show
that i am watching right now
is lovecraft country reviews over on the
break room of geeks subscribe to that
channel if you have not already
thank you thank you very much
um that was a smoothly inserted plug
nice glide action on that um
would you agree that the 10th doctor
overall is a little overrated i would
agree that the 10th doctor is very
overrated
still good i love tennant but he's
more than a little uh overrated actually
going back to uni soon really hope to
get past
this writer's block i've been in for
some time
any tips on coming up with ideas or new
premises nope
joel you're talking to someone who
launched a kickstarter
for a book that they started conceiving
18
years ago i have been banging away at
the same ideas
for an embarrassingly long amount of
time i'm not someone to ask on where to
get
new ideas from
uh have you seen the jekyll and hyde
musical only listen uh to some of the
songs but i think
it really gets the source material nope
i never have no
no that's not true i saw
at a friend's house a few years ago they
had
they had the david hasselhoff version
so if the thing's any good i couldn't
appreciate it because i was laughing at
hoff overacting
it was a great time but it wasn't good
i put together an oc cosplay for my own
incarnation of the meddling monk it's
basically an old and american preacher
type look
the hat was from a v for vendetta mask
set
ooh very curious to see that actually
if they casted you as the doctor would
you do it i mean
they shouldn't i'm not british
and i mean i suppose with professional
coaching i could fake a decent british
accent
but setting that issue aside
[ __ ] yes
like dear god yes any reality show
guilty pleasures
i don't know if i've ever owned up to
this before
so i don't watch reality tv shows now
there was a period in time where i was
being
paid to write
about jersey shore
and i liked it i liked
that show
oh boy wasn't the only thing i was being
paid to write about i was also writing
about house
while that was airing but yeah i was
professionally writing about jersey
shore
uh my only saving grace is the site that
that was for is now completely gone so
this stuff is scrubbed from the internet
uh
i'm sorry but in the words of buffy
billy
uh billy idol got his look from spike oh
well fine if you're gonna be continuity
nitpicker about it
uh we all suck at research oh good it's
not just me
what characters in your book are you
most like and why
so i'm not gonna name the characters
but there there are two characters
neither of them are the lead
but they are the closest to my own
direct proxy
and basically one of them
behaves the way i would like to think i
would behave
in the circumstances at the end the
other one behaves the way
i suspect i would actually behave
in the circumstances that they are in
so that i'm kind of split between two
uh every so often i check sondheim is
still alive and he is so yay yes
yes yay for sondheim zootopia moana
personal choice moana i do think
zootopia is actually a better movie
though
uh council of geeks has pulled to george
rr martin but with much
better excuse for taking so long to
write a book
i'm not sure i actually do have a better
excuse to be honest
last thing i watched was goth and my
kidnappers are gonna have an interesting
time
oh yeah especially depending on what
season
uh is your interest in flux and things
arriving in the middle part of the
reason capaldi is your favorite doctor
and you want to mention
you like pragmatic heroes um
it's probably part of it i
i mean i enjoy pragmatic heroes because
i'm a pragmatic person at the end of the
i'm a pr
i'm a pragmatist and a consequentialist
i i i do not get hung up on the
principle of the thing
and i care much more about the end
result than
than you know being hung up on
you know purity of of means to get it
i'm not gonna go so far to say i'm ends
justify the means i'm
not but like if there's a goal that i
think is worth getting
i'm not gonna get excessively hung up on
the quote-unquote right way
to get us there so yeah i do appreciate
that and i think what a big part of what
i appreciate i
appreciate about capaldi is is partly
that because i love his
journey from series 8 to series 10 and
how he
changes over the course of that because
he has an arc which
i would argue no other doctor really has
certainly not to the extent that he does
pretty much every other doctor arrives
more or less fully
formed and stays the same maybe we as an
audience come to better understand them
as it goes on during their era
but they don't actually change i think
so i think something like that applies
to tenant
we realize how dark he can go
towards the end of his run and how
selfish he can be
but that doesn't feel like it's new it's
just something we hadn't
seen whereas capaldi actually feels like
he changes
and i actually really appreciate that on
a lot of levels
to be honest it's not water it's apple
juice and lemonade oh
no they found me out
your bubbly water is a very nice head
i will leave that comment alone i do
have a lot of
middling themes theming
crop up but because i'm bisexual that
makes sense
uh what is your thoughts on the omen and
the exorcist i have actually not seen
the omen start to finish
i've seen most of it like in bits and
pieces sporadically over time
um i do like the exorcist i think it's
overrated
um there there are very few older horror
movies that i think hold up
that said my absolute favorite horror
movie is from 1978 so you know
i do think older horror movies can't
work but
um yeah the exorcist is
fine i think a lot of it at the time it
came out
was shock value not like in the generic
oh we're gonna have a kids swear way but
just like it pushed the envelope in
terms of stuff people hadn't seen on
screen before
but by the time i saw it i was in
college when i saw it
and you know it just i was like yeah
that's pretty well done
that was kind of it i think i i honestly
think the omen's a better spectacle
than the exorcist how would you feel
about
setting up a table read for your play
over zoom or youtube or something
so my first question is have you read
the play
i would be very curious to find any
um actors willing to do that live
and perform those characters under those
circumstances
um like i'd be game
but first of all the
the video or the stream or whatever i
did would get demonetized immediately
so i've talked about it sporadically the
play that i wrote
available on amazon buy now beat the
rush um
it's called when she wakes uh published
under the name of vera wilde
it's an exploration of bdsm
it there's a re the reason i published
it was because even though i have
inroads with local community theaters in
my area
there was no way they were ever going to
put this on
if i could have gotten it staged i would
have
but if you're curious check the play out
it's actually relatively cheap it's
cheaper than my
um than my other book um
so you know give that a read leave a
review hasn't had a review in a little
while that'd be nice
i do think it actually reads pretty well
despite being a play i would love to see
it staged at some point though
oh that would make me so happy
uh how was your last book in terms
were you pleased with how it did um i've
actually with
skirting gender i've been very happy
with it and it has continued to sell
at a fairly steady pace since it came
out not
not in high volume but like it's never
completely dropped off which is really
um gratifying
for me to see that i i love that oh you
know what i got
i i have um questions from the discord
that i need to check
i almost forgot i've i've been trying to
do that earlier in the
stream especially if i'm going to
hydrate
as much as i have been so
let me just pull those up i'll be right
back folks
uh i've got them set up uh already
where did why is why is it not
oh here we go so
a reminder the discord is a patreon
exclusive perk
so join the council of geeks patreon and
take part in that
um is shipping included in the backing
price for physical copies
um yes when you support at a level
to get a physical copy the cost of
shipping is
um added to that so it and
it is higher if it's international
shipping
i hate having to do that but it's the
reality of
my having to ship these things out i
learned that the hard way with skirting
gender i had a couple of
volumes that i had to ship outside the
us and it
it goes a lot really quick
um how do you feel about indie short
films in general any
genre a favorite uh what do you look for
in a short film
i used to be animated shorts are usually
my go-to if i'm going to take in
short films um that's that's
usually what i like to see live action
shorts
are um hard for me
i'm not entirely sure why but they they
don't grab me as often uh when you
select the option to get a drop
down list of country oh sorry sorry they
were answering the other question
for me favorite darren aronofsky movie
for me it's a
close tie between mother and requiem for
a dream the fountain
hands down not even close i still
haven't seen mother actually
uh what is your view on film rating
systems uh take say the us
uh pretty much a child of any age can be
taken to anything unless rated nc 17 it
seems and the uk and the uk
hard age lines are at 15 usually strong
violence and horror and then
um usually really strong violence or
very strong
sex including real but non-pornographic
uh
such as short busts short bus
bush
but both classifications can be shown
easily in mainstream cinemas um
i mean the us raving system is a mess
but it's because it doesn't actually
have
a hard and firm rules that it follows
it's just the whims of whoever's on the
board of the mpaa
at the time and you can't cite precedent
for what was allowed in a certain rating
in previous years as a reason why you
should get say a pg-13 and not be
labeled an r so like that process is
messed up
as far as what you're saying
specifically i actually kind of favored
the
uk model where you couldn't take
a as someone under the age of 15
into the um equivalent of an r rated
movie
whereas in the u.s you can you can take
a kid into anything that is an nc 17
provided they're accompanied by a parent
which i
i i don't love and i especially don't
love it because
i grew up in that age when
r-rated films were marketed at kids
like i grew up um
at a time when kids my age were seeing
robocop and terminator 2
and there were toys and massive
marketing
aimed at us at kids and i'm like these
are
not kid movies well terminator 2
arguably
but you know robocop what the
what the f flip in hell
ah i said [ __ ] earlier
why am i censoring myself now i don't
know
but yeah so so that's it for that
because i am i am now doing a cut off
for the discord questions if there are
ones that came in
after those i will answer them in the
discord itself
um so now i am even further behind in
the chat than i already was
what did you think of the ds9 episode
the visitor i loved it tony todd was so
good such a heart-wrenching episode i
mean i've got a review up
for it because i was actually
commissioned to review that and one
other episode
of uh ds9 um it was it was very good and
i love tony todd he's
terrific and it was nice to see him
you know not have to play creepy because
he's
ever since candyman that's kind of been
the uh
presumption that if you cast tony todd
it's
casting him to be creepy so it was kind
of nice to see him do something
other than that um
whoo geez um
wow i am so far behind it's not even
funny
okay i'm gonna try and not linger as
long on some of these questions so
uh is it bad that i was on a ferris
wheel recently i saw a girl
panicking in a pod next to me and said
to my godmother loudly
you know it's five years since this
wheel collapsed
yes yes that is bad
no not even gonna mince words uh ever
seen the show must go on
everything the show must go online
videos of shakespeare plays i found a
complete book of
shakespeare plays so i could read along
while watching the videos no
not familiar with those so i just
pledged 25
to the kickstarter but i just noticed
that they're
charging me for shipping too so yeah if
i
chipped in ten dollars more could you
maybe autograph
um i know that the
um the shipping is is
nudging people uh off it a little bit
i've seen that come up
elsewhere but here's here's what i'll
say usually um
the i believe it is 35
tier on the patreon which currently
allows you to get a copy of a book
signed by me once this book is published
that'll be an option on that um
on that support tier on patreon because
right now you either get a copy of the
play
or of skirting gender but once this once
this book actually gets published
and i have physical copies in my hand
that will be an option as well so if you
want to get a signed copy for 35
on the patreon for 30 for that amount
will get you there once it's done and
ready
that's sort of the thing with
kickstarter you do need to realize
oftentimes you are paying slightly more
than you would pay
once it's available to the public but
that's kind of the nature of
crowdfunding
um so what are your thoughts on it
chapter one and two um neither is very
good
second one's worse uh neither is great
uh speaking of fan fiction any thoughts
on lindsay ellis's
omega verse video jesus that was nuts it
was a well done video
like i knew what omega verse was i was
aware
i'd heard of it and i knew some of the
ins and outs of it
i didn't know the legal insanity that
was going on
um behind the scenes what is that what
is that
there's something in the bottom of my
glass
i don't know what that is i'm still
gonna drink it
um been subscribed for a while catching
a livestream
live screen
live stream for for the first time in a
while
uh just back up backed up on patreon is
davey jones from
pirates of the caribbean movies the most
underrated villain ever
um
i don't know i mean the thing is i like
davey jones but i
always liked barbosa more like i
loved barbosa so much in the first
pirates of the caribbean and i like
davey jones but he's always been
overshadowed for me
it's not his fault i love bill nye he
does great work but i
i can't help it no when i say atrocious
human being i mean slaughtering the
entire crew of a ship because she's
sobering up uh no i've never written a
character like that
uh are you reading or have read
accession yet
no i've actually only just today
finished the book that i was
commissioned to read
prior to accession so that is the next
one i am starting
by the time you see the next um
live stream i will have started reading
it
uh if it wasn't for doctor who and dark
materials i question why i pay the
license fee
uh ever listen to david tennant's
podcast david tennant does a podcast
with
i haven't i've heard of it um but i've
never gotten around to it see the thing
is i'm so far behind on the podcast i
already listened to
that like this is the one
quite possibly the only major downside
of having been laid off from my job
sitting at my job
i listened mostly to podcasts but the
thing is i don't listen to podcasts
when i'm doing stuff here because when
i'm working on
editing or i'm shooting or whatever i
can't
have ambient noise like it's not
mindless work
i have to be engaged for me to do it
right whereas at my job i would
frequently be doing mindless work that i
could just have a podcast on
so i've fallen so far behind on podcasts
since i was laid off it's crazy
what are your thoughts on steven
schwartz don't know him
uh also so coming from work
don't tell my manager oh
i'm on a water break
i've been working on the same idea since
i was 15 or 16
and of course i'm actually 37 so
i do think i've been banging at it as
long as you yes
jolie you and me just banging away
somebody's going to clip that out of
context
another [ __ ] a david hasselhoff was
wonderfully awful
jekyll and hyde uh colleen sexton was
the best thing about that version she
played lucy i don't really i don't
remember anyone other than hasselhoff in
that
like he just created this vortex of suck
it was great um what's the
link to your far skate podcast again
i've listened to the first four and
jessie's reactions are priceless
since she's watching for the first time
if you just google council of geeks
podcast you'll find it
also you can go to the community tab on
uh
the council of geeks uh youtube channel
because i post links there as well
trying to catch up i'm not going to is
there a movie or tv show that you hate
but everyone else seems to love and vice
versa
um i i couldn't get into rick and morty
that seems to be the big one that
everyone like is
in absolute love with i'm just like no
it's not for me
um as far as something that i love that
no one else does i don't know
there's stuff that i love that no one
else remembers like the max
nobody remembers the max and i adore it
i recently went to madame tussauds and
blackpool
wax museum all for celebrities uh and my
god
uh jody whitaker is really small
let's see uh
what's the thesis of we created jk
rowling going to be
is it just going to be that she
shouldn't be famous if we didn't buy her
stuff
okay so dropped a little bit
of what one of the videos that i'm
planning for next month is going to be
which has a working title of
we created jody would occur and no
that's not going to be what it's about
it's going to be much more about
how the fandom
sort of primed her to
quote unquote ignore the haters and how
when she felt attacked by people trying
to point out that her beliefs were
transphobic the people that she
retreated to
were the ones who fed her those talking
points in the first place and it just
reinforced
their perspective as far as she was
concerned and i'll go into more detail
when i get to there last thing i watched
was hannibal oh dear
uh do you still watch stranger things i
mean it's not a question because there
hasn't been a new season in a while but
yeah i guess
if you were stuck watching an episode of
doctor who forever
would you prefer hell bend or orphan 55.
what are your thoughts on the dark
crystal movie's pretty good show
is excellent
uh i get self condos about characters i
write becoming
too self insert so i just uh
include traits that give them distance
from me that works
i mean like everyone's got a different
process and that's fine you should try
amaretto and apple juice
it's such a good drink i actually i hate
amaretto
i actually hate almond flavor i like
almonds any time i've had anything
that's like almond flavored like
amaretto i hate it
ah it's awful i'm the same way with
bananas i like bananas i hate banana
flavored stuff
have you reached death in heaven at this
point um so
it won't go up for uh a while but yeah
i i shot my i did my re-watch and shot
my review for death in heaven a while
back
actually uh is halloween 1978 your
favorite horror movie
no good guess but no
uh i say good guess i've actually never
seen that movie the audiobook i was
recording has started being
uploaded my friend uh is doing fan-made
audio books and audio dramas of the old
doctor who books by virgin publishing oh
very cool
uh do you remember me asking you ages
ago
if missy putting clara and 12 together
and lowering them
to 3w this way fits into this is all
part of my plan trope
i don't know because it's at least as
far as i've gotten in the re-watch
it is not clear that missy intended
the consequences of what happened
when um clara and the doctor
met so she takes credit for putting them
together
and for seeing how the two of them would
basically be toxic for each other
um but at least as far as i've gotten in
the rewatch she never tries to take
credit
for the specific events that result
from that only that she thought putting
them together would create a nice bit of
chaos
so i don't think it falls under that
trope at least
not and not as far as i've gotten uh in
the re-watch
i'm submitting my application for the
table read of the play
i don't know what part i just want to be
part of things joel there's only two
parts
and i love you man but you i unless
you've got
an insanely deep voice i i
think you're gonna sound a little young
for the
for the male role in that play
wow i am so far behind on this isn't
even funny bdsm
so this is talking about the way bdsm or
50 shades bdsm
bdsm 50 shades is not bdsm
50 shades is
wrong on
many many many many many levels that
have been better dissected by other
youtubers so
i shall waste no more breath upon it
i'll read it live and i've done a decent
amount of stage acting i'm one thousand
percent serious
you folks say this you haven't read it
the second you said bdsm i was on amazon
you kinky bastards
uh i should have just said i wrote a
kink play
ages ago and you all you all would have
bought it
i don't know i've i'm not i haven't been
ashamed but i've been
hesitant to talk about it um
i don't know why i suppose just because
i i guess i try and keep my brand
uh or the council of geeks side of my
brand
uh more or less family friendly but
you know i'm i'm well hydrated tonight
so there you go
okay what the hell is that that's in
there
ah i gotta take my rings off to get this
bugging me eh
oh what is that
i have no idea what that is it's just a
black spot
it's the curse of the black spot the
siren's coming for me
okay i have no idea what time it is i'm
gonna keep it going
normally it's an hour i'm having fun
i hope you are too
let's be very clear about something this
is a bad idea
i might be making review videos soon any
advice
um be sure you talk about things that
you are passionate about one way or the
other
that you either really like or really
dislike the hardest stuff to review
stuff that you are meh
on and uh try not to
rope yourself into anything long term if
you are at all
uncertain about being able to commit to
it so like don't start doing episode by
episode reviews of something that you
don't already know you're gonna want to
see through
uh you want to see yourself your show
staged i've got actors and camera
equipment i'll see what i can do
hey look if somebody gets their hands on
the play
and wants to stage it that's fine but
like
i i want to see video of a rehearsal
at the very least
a drunk review of all six seasons of
glee they even did an episode of grease
wow glee is a show that i have
very deliberately avoided
excuse me wheezy would laughter about
you watching jersey
shore oh my secret shame
ah i tend to watch shows based on
cooking like top chef and master chefs
dude the thing is i don't consider those
reality shows
i mean i suppose they are they're
reality competitions
but i don't that's not what i think of
what i think reality show
and now i've got hiccups terrific
i also really recently got into the mass
singer for some reason
nope never seen that that one oh god
this
this is gonna be bad
oh dang it
i was accompanied by my grandparents
when i went to see deadpool that was
awkward oh yeah
that that that would be oh boy
me me hiccupping yeah that's another
thing that could be clipped out of
context
oh god this is bad this is really bad
i always felt that there's a ton of
potential for a bdsm centered comedy
especially
with all the many many niches i mean i
know netflix
tried i think i watched the first
episode i forget what it was called
it wasn't great the problem is to really
do
do it properly you would have to get
someone who
really knows bdsm not someone who has
just
looked up a list a list of kinks and is
picking on them
because there's stuff to be made fun of
within the bdsm community but
i will always attest that the people
best equipped to make fun of something
are the people who love it the people
who don't understand it that well
will never be able to write jokes as
good as people who know it inside and
out
oh my god this is bad
oh lord
what are your thoughts on stephen king
i've
actually never read his work directly i
i tried and um like something about his
writing style put me off
t2 for kids for older kids just about
robocop is sadistic in places so so
no yes that's that yeah i'm with you on
that never mind
not counting lauren in your top 10 angel
characters what about
what about harmony i do enjoy harmony
she's fun
most embarrassing awkward movie you saw
with your parents
i actually don't have anything that
leaps to mind at all for the
for that
is was the champagne champagne
good um i don't know what you're talking
about i'm drinking
water
oh god um
so tell me have you seen birdemic no
i don't and i won't
unless somebody pays me i'm not watching
that thing
which ducktales do you prefer new or old
the new
which which is a blast for me for people
my age but
it's true schwartz wrote pippin godspell
and wicked
oh okay okay i don't know pippin i was
in godspell in high school and i like
wicked
i have drinking horn and i've used it
frequently during virtual
happy hours drinking horns sounds
awesome i should put one of those
those on my amazon whistle wist list
wish list i should probably think about
wrapping this up i'm noticing that the
number of viewers has
i started to go down i don't know if
they presume it's because i'm wrapping
up or if people are just getting sick of
my
well hydrated hiccuping self the doctor
who audio audiobook i've been recording
has started releasing one of my friends
is doing a family oh yeah no i read that
i'm fine um i'd fund the kickstarter but
uh i already don't have any free funds
spent
that on doctor who fair enough
did you get the first time lord
victorious titan comic nope
my issue isn't that uh i'm stuck on one
story for years is that i can't even
begin to decide
what of my 105 plus yeah literally
stories to work on not counting movies
uh and short film ideas just pick one
like seriously eliminate the
element eliminate the five that are
the least likely to yield dividends
go go online find a find a random number
generator to basically roll 100-sided
die
and just pick one
um also happy
that oh geez
oh my god these hiccups also happy that
sodheim september
uh everybody i'm jamming to company
sweeney
into the woods and sending the park with
george all month very nice
you said jodie whittaker instead of jk
rowling back then did i
crap blame it on the water
there's a new animated film from cartoon
saloon
coming soon to apple tv it's called wolf
walkers and it looks
like it has the potential to be a modern
masterpiece that's great
but i don't have apple tv i'm not sure
i'm up for springing for another service
if any living doctor could read your
book for audible who would you want ooh
um like i want to say cavaldi because
he's my favorite but i think the accent
is gonna be
inscrutable um over the whole
run of the thing um
mcgann he's got the silky voice
easy reference list for play readers
actors who would be interested
sitting council of geeks for my work oh
god
are you seriously casting for my
freaking bdsm kink play
in the live stream stream chat
that's awesome and amazing
you have the best glare when you
responded to that hellbent versus over
55 question
curious i personally rather watch help
ben forever than orphan 55 no question
i suppose if i was to actually answer
that
uh it would be hellbent mainly because
i'm gonna put this down
before before i spill it from hiccups
um i think mainly because um
i i think part of me would
like still be trying to figure out what
the hell moffitt was thinking
or from 55 i know exactly what they were
thinking it just didn't work
nbaa rating system sucks but it
was worse with the production code oh
yeah no agreed the hayes codes
the haze code
was super [ __ ]
we're improving you didn't yell at me
uh missy gets to have all the plans she
wants
like that time she went other undercover
in a non-magical school and then a
magical school
i'm assuming that was one of the audios
what are your thoughts on stand by me
from 1986 good movie
holds up well did you see the new
mandalorian
images from this week nope i just hope
the actual vid comes out before november
i'm trying not to imagine the future
after that oh
november's a scary month this year i
took the line missy says
you would go to hell if she asked and
she did
as an indication that she somehow
planned making the doctor
look uh for an afterlife
um because danny
um
i'm not sure i'd i'd buy that
i mean she was trying to lure the doctor
in and was leaving breadcrumbs for him i
think she
figured he'd find her eventually and was
just waiting for whenever that was
before she pulled the trigger
50 shades is what wine moms think is
bdsm
no that's it that is an insult to wine
moms
so no i reject that uh oh nathaniel just
wondering how are you faring with
the mind block twist of chapter four
paper mario or have you
not reached it yet i haven't reached it
yet i just today
reached the creepy
creepy steeple i think it is
so i don't think i've gotten it yet i've
just been dealing with people turned
into pigs
oh my god this is getting
like parody level ridiculous
ah who read fifty shades of grey better
george decay or gilbert grand free oh
godfrey he gave it the gravitas that it
deserved
if your play sells really well suddenly
is this now a bdsm
channel no because the book was
published under vera wilds
so the viral wild channel would suddenly
be a bdsm channel
uh have watched today your very old
doctor who videos and there were some
very interesting thoughts about female
who like
building it up and speculating yeah i've
left up the video
about my initial very negative
thoughts about the concept of a woman
playing doctor who which
that video was put out years before
whitaker was cast
and i
i leave that up because it was an
accurate representation of my
feelings at the time and i think it's
important to sort of leave up
the fact that that was where i started
and i sort of worked my way through my
feelings by the time
jody actually started appearing in the
role
uh weird question
this this live stream no
but once quarantine is lifted fully and
it's all behind us
would you ever do a live stream with liz
i don't
i'm not sure live streaming is her bag
like i think i forget when it was there
was
one live stream i did where she was
actually like sitting on the other side
of the room
what while i did it
so it's just not really her thing
uh the submission is barely if even
consensual and
and stage is clearly not masochistic
50 shades isn't bdsm it's bs yes
agreed aside from and that's not
getting into the fact that 50 shades of
grey equates bdsm
with damage and abusive controlling
relationships which
and any healthy bdsm relationship is
like any healthy vanilla relationship
in that it is it lives or
dies on clear communication between
those involved
and if that is not present then it's not
healthy
and that's true of any relationship
okay also i'm interested to know what
you think of the
of the bag guy aliens you know how some
conservative people can be fun to be
around unless you're in a group
they hate that time's a thousand well
i'll be curious to see when i get there
um
oh hang on the chat jumped on me again
oh my god
oh my god this is this is nuts
uh what is your favorite movie from the
disney renaissance
little mermaid you have a cute hiccup
thank you
uh it was called bonding i actually
enjoyed it not
sure what that was in reference to bang
did that cure your hiccups
probably not please drink a glass of
non-sparkling water hang upside down
with a straw
if you need help guaranteeing a hiccup
cure i know but like i'd have to get up
from the live stream and i'm not gonna
let you watch me try and do that
everyone take a shot every time there's
there's a hiccup no
you will be dead if you do that
um i also fell behind in my poc cast
when i came home because i usually
listen to them in the car
and haven't driven my own car until
recently
how many shots does it take to get drunk
depends on what it is
um me these days
three will get me well tipsy for four
will probably get me
plowed i'm a lightweight now i didn't
used to be
but i am these days i'm gonna blame the
estrogen
the estrogen on that uh
i'm saying for as long as you're
hiccuping it's delightful you're going
to be here
a while my issue isn't that i'm stuck on
one story for years is that i can't even
begin to say oh
yeah you people was smart and repeated
your questions
as if i wasn't trying to hang back and
catch up on them
oh it's the thing i keep saying i'm
gonna stop doing and i do it every time
regardless
this is oh that i feel like this live
stream is
becoming a disaster piece
uh hiccup cure when you finish recording
eat a spoonful of peanut
butter oh no ah
what will you do if you get really
successful from this first installment
probably um
prioritize the follow-up which is
i don't know probably eighty-five
percent done the first draft
pink elephants are heffa lumps and
woozles ah pink elves
pink elephants please what are your
thoughts on sound of music i actually
haven't seen it all the way through
start to finish
blaming on the water needs to be on a
t-shirt i've already got the
i've already got um
this sucker on a t-shirt i don't think i
need two water
t-shirts ah
i recently started helping my friend
work on a comic
it's the crow reimagined as a woman oh
nice that's true the crow always was
done as a man what
wasn't it oh yeah
do you play d and d i haven't been a
while i love it my character is a gender
flu
swashbuckling sea elf pirate rogue nice
last character last character i played
was a half orc barbarian
um i forgot about the other my my gaming
group which hasn't met
in years at this point because the guy
who used to host
now has kids so it all got more
complicated
but we didn't always do d d like he
he hosted a star wars uh role play game
where i was i was an astro droid
um a lovecraft
one where i died i think three times i
was on my third character
for that we did transformers at one
point where
my transformer changed into a delorean
and i was required to say my catchphrase
um
1.21 gigawatts of whoop ass every time i
transformed
um so we we gamed a bit but
but we only did d and d i think the once
excuse me and now a
reminder that in your fate that you're
that in your fate is
a doctor in distress video
part of me wonders if i should record
that right after this
while hiccuping and
hydrated
oh dear missy was a reference to her
other roles she was
in a trash uk sitcom called bad
education and then sabrina i know she's
on sabrina
uh liz is trying to get me to to try
sabrina she know
she knows she won't get me onto
riverdale
why don't we make this a 24-hour stream
no
no you're gonna get me killed
and the tony for best book of play goes
to when she wakes oh
the tonys wouldn't touch that thing with
a 12 foot pole
uh that that had a violet wand on the
end of it
uh since i know what your favorite
horror film
is i wonder if that has ruined amazing
grace being played as spock's
uh funeral forever no
that still works but yeah there there is
a creepy overtone there
uh are there any bdsm videos on veera's
channel not
as yet that
there will be
don't promise as to when because
for what i want to do with it it's gonna
be a
beast to shoot but there will be
oh god
i don't think the breadcrumbs were
planted by missy people like
the robots in the cockpit cyborg were
looking for it without prompting from
her i watched dr undistressed for the
first time i don't get what everyone's
whinging about well i'll find out one of
these days who do you think would
uh would work better as the doctor judy
dench or answer
angela angela
angela lansbury um
between those two i mean like i would
happily see
either of those but i
i'm gonna favor dame judy for that one
i love that angela lansbury's still
alive though
oh don't let don't let my having said
it said that jinx please
what are your thoughts on high school
musical i've only seen the first one
it's not bad it's not great
but it's not bad um
i love how many fans hated the doctor
becoming a woman
when simne when sidney
newman suggested making the doctor a
woman in the late 80s
when they were looking for the seventh
doctor
was that publicly known that he did that
though
like i know that was brought up when
whitaker was eventually
cast but like was that public knowledge
that he was suggesting that
back then i don't remember hearing that
oh god thank you tracy
god you're so freaking generous
and the rest of you are also nice and
indulging
are there any classic villains that have
not been brought back yet for classic
who that you think would work
well in knew who omega
come up on just
come on
i i remember hearing somewhere and i
haven't looked into it because
it would be research uh
but i remember hearing somewhere that
there's an
issue with the estate of the writer who
created him
um that either they want too much money
or too much
control for bringing him back into the
tv show
i don't know if that's true but if it's
not
freaking just do it
come on he's like the only major
recurring
villain of classic who
who hasn't come back yet they've been
bringing back
one time characters they broke big
freaking alpha centauri
and they haven't brought back omega
the hell
the hell
oh god are they gone
are they gone i think they're gone
wonder of wonder miracle of miracles
okay that's like i'm holding your breath
for 30 seconds
apparently i just needed to rant about
omega
uh a christmas story home alone or elf
uh christmas story
then home alone then elf the the tail
end of elf loses me a little bit
you may skip this at in training for
your relearning to not answer every
question you're given
charleston that was cruel
have you uh watched torchwood or sarah
jane adventures then if you have what
are your thoughts on them i have seen
the first
three series of torchwood i have not
seen miracle day
i did i have like the first two series
of
torchwood are so up and down they are so
all over the place sometimes it's great
a lot of the times it's mess sometimes
it is painful
children of earth is amazing and dark
and it hurt me
like deeply um
sarah jane adventures i did the first
two seasons of and it was fine it was
very clearly aimed at a much younger
demographic than doctor who and that's
fine that's good even but that also
means it wasn't really for me and i
didn't connect with it that much
but it was fine uh
let's see somebody had a recommendation
for what to do for my hiccups that they
just
message is now retracted
what are your hobbies um
that's that's a good question because
it used to be that youtube was my hobby
but now it's kind of my living
i don't know what my hobbies are now
i'm having an existential crisis all of
a sudden over the week that i just
realized
i don't have a thing to do with my spare
time
because the thing i do with my spare
time
is now the thing that makes my living
it's my work day
i don't know
wow okay that was a really simple
question that just
blew my mind can i just say for the
record
this is the best live stream i watch
good
i'm glad somebody's enjoying it
you made my day mainly you're adorable
it comes in a terrible laugh
thank you for making me smile i am happy
to help
what's your opinion of transformers
warfare cybertron
i have none uh
all right where did i leave off
uh
what are your thoughts on jim carrey's
the grinch and mike myers cat the hat
jim carrey's the grinch was painful mike
mike's got the hat i refuse to watch
so unless somebody pays me i will never
see it
looking back what are your thoughts now
on good omens the book of the show
show's great book was good i haven't
although to be fair i haven't reread the
book i read the book
in high school um
because i knew it was douglas
adams-esque
uh and i quite enjoyed it
and i thought the show was great so
thumbs up to both of them which makes it
two thumbs up
hey that was lousy
there will be bdsm videos on veera's
channel
we'll see if i remember later on
to check to see if there was a sudden
subscriber spike
today to coincide with a bunch of people
from this chat with me saying i will at
some point do a bdsm video over there
suddenly subscribing to that channel
that would amuse me greatly
i don't expect it to be the case but
that would amuse me greatly
uh vera i tell you oh thank you carowind
sorry thank you so
thank you so much i appreciate you
greatly
you are wonderful so tomorrow
is not going to be the standard take to
doctor who review
tomorrow i am taking part in a
collaborative
um event called one fantastic scene you
might remember last year there was one
excellent scene where a bunch of
different geeky youtube channels
um talked about their favorite scenes
from an x-men movie
this is going to be a bunch of who tube
channels
talking about their favorite scene from
christopher eccleston's time
uh as the doctor now it's going to be
done
as a premiere tomorrow
9 30 a.m eastern standard time i
actually had the time wrong before
um in my head because they had told me
the time and i didn't account for the
fact that the person who organized it
shebogan who is in the uk and the time
he gave me was uk time i didn't
backtrack it
but what it's going to be is 9 30 a.m
premiere
for my contribution to one fantastic
scene
thank you carowind i appreciate you
immensely
uh
let's see saying a bdsm video
uh will be a beast to shoot maybe you
think it's going to be an adult video
not quite to that level
probably
see now part of me is is tempted to do
like a director's cut version of the
video that i'm planning
to do oh dear
oh god if the hiccups started up again
so help me
have you watched musical theater mash
he's a youtube channel i think you guys
could get along
i have not thank you ben even though you
retracted whatever your message was i
appreciate the help
did you watch sesame street going up oh
yeah grover was my favorite all the way
joanna lumley uh was flooded for the
doctor when tom baker was stepping down
so it's not remotely new oh
so her being in um
curse of the fatal death was like also
an inside joke
in addition to ha ha what if the doctor
was a woman
in two years you'll be 40 shut your
mouth
that is not true
in a year and a half i'll be 40.
ah
omega cured your hiccups yes apparently
i was talking to a friend who's only
seen buffy and not seen
angel he said he didn't like darla i
hope that changes
i mean i i have friends who don't really
care for liz doesn't like her that much
actually
um
let's see goddammit somehow redacted my
message you should definitely watch
doctor in distress now
we'll see uh we'll see
children of earth hurt you yeah you
really should listen
to my audio series oh dear
okay let's see
oh i'm almost caught up do you ever
refer to anyone as darling
i don't think i do
not not to my conscious
hazy knowledge ever heard of the
pre-code
hollywood era it was brief period from
1929 to 1934 when the
code was poorly enforced and anything
went in hollywood yes
i am familiar i don't think i've ever
seen any films specifically from that
era but i do know about it
your hobbies are going to a winery with
liz
and not me
like that's not a hobby that's a
couple's outing that's that's
a little different and i don't do it
frequently enough for it to be a hobby
although i do it fairly frequently
who is your favorite immortal in the old
guard the
the names have completely escaped me the
two guys who were a couple both of them
together
i'm not splitting them up and only
counting one i'm cutting them both
i'm currently doing a re-watch of i
claudius really worth watching
if you want to see the war doctrine war
master as roman emperors
i have a i have a friend on um the
podcast network that
tuff like a girl is on the fire and
water probably has a network rob
he loves claudia's it's like his
favorite thing ever i still haven't seen
it
i know what your new hobby can be even
more she-ra
one of these days i'd love to see a
podcast devote itself to
pre-code films beyond a single episode
topic and other film podcasts maybe i
should create one myself
go for it i honestly believe that 80
of podcasts are created by somebody
going boy i wish someone would make a
podcast of it and then just saying screw
it and do it themselves
uh second best live stream first for me
was
2019 uh
uh was 2019 new year's
won uh because of the endnotes
uh i don't even remember now
your favorite horror then is points and
screams
yes very wise
i can't do the scream right nobody can
because it's an after effect
uh do your old job as a hobby [ __ ] no
never
uh
let's see there will be a bdsm video on
beerus channel subscribe
second uh
you got me through lockdown for real oh
felix thank you i i
if anything i do helps anybody in any
way even if it
is only to make for a nice way to pass
the time that is honestly a wonderful
thing
to me i've watched your channel for
years now but i've started watching
doctor who two weeks ago
wow started with series one new doctor
now in series three i sew miss cycleston
but who is great
yes it is all great and i'll have my
video giving my little
praise of my favorite moment for
michelson's time
up tomorrow i i got i i slid
two plugs right in there nice and snug
uh
have you ever been to broadwaycon no
cannot say that i have i did not know
that was a thing there's nothing wrong
with being
40. i certainly hope not because it's
coming
if you watch sesame street growing up
did you see the controversial episode
where margaret hamilton reprises her
her road her role as wicked witch of the
east i did not
i
vera wilde and lin-man while miranda
collaborate to make a hip-hop
musical about the invention of bdsm
starring anthony ramos and sutton
foster you guys are having a lot of fun
without me i'm not
even sure i need to be here start
singing
you've got a friend in me
oh dear and i won't sing any more than
that because i've had i've had
these things get disrupted by the
friggin bots because i sang more than a
bar
any bad movie recommendations having
some friends over on friday my first
choice is currently wickerman with nick
cage that works
my personal recommendation ice and fire
by uh the ralph bakshi it's
so bad it's
it is it is left out of too many
so bad it's funny conversations i
recommend that one
do you plan on watching the boys i
really don't
i don't like warren ellis i'm sorry
i don't the guy who plays homeland is
such an amazing actor
truly scary every time he's on screen i
mean that's great
i just i don't like the writer
i just i'm sorry
um queen or the beatles queen
fight me did you read any of the buffy
comics
yes i read all of
season eight
it wasn't good so i did not keep going
after that
gina thank you tell us how you really
feel about your old job
you don't want to hear how i really feel
about my old job
you don't
ah thank you for this evening it's been
wonderful good night yeah other people
are signing off maybe i should take that
as a clue
sometime soon
oh john look at you mingling with the
locals and skirting by under the radar
you sneaky bugger
uh any books that you'd love to see
adapted for film or tv
um i'd like to see
uh somebody take a crack at christopher
moore's work
to be honest and like not skimp on the
weird
i would personally do um
the bloodsucking fiends bite me you suck
trilogy as a tv series
uh are you sure this channel isn't a
bdsm channel already
uh you asked us to be your subs and keep
inserting plugs
ah you people do me proud
margaret hamilton was the wicked witch
of the west yeah i i
i know who she was i still never saw
that episode of um
sesame street recently watched a film
called
little joe about a flower that changes
people's personality
very body snatchers-esque ooh
that sounds creepy
uh what are your thoughts on the lost
boys oh it's fun
that's a good movie legitimately i
really do like that
when will you review in the forest of
the night i
whenever the weekly schedule of the take
two review gets to it
i will tell you i've already shot my
review for in the force of the night i
don't know how far down the line it
goes up because i'm hydrated and i'm not
gonna do the math on that
right now actually you know what hold on
i've got my docket up
or i i've got it here and i can pull it
up so
in the forest of the night
oh yeah so that's just gonna be next
week
i just got bumped one week everything
just got moved forward one week because
of the
um one fantastic scene thing
uh there's a scene where a woman has
her dog put down because that was not my
dog oh my god
all right i'm already unsettled just
from that
so bad it's good recommendation the
swarm with michael caine supposed to be
seriously is
supposed to be seriously supposed to be
serious went horribly wrong in an
amazingly bizarre way
i am going to have to wrap this up soon
my phone's battery is dying
what is your favorite queen song oh god
um
i don't even know it changes day to day
there's like there's so many good ones
this is awful i tend to come back to fat
bottom girls as like my comfort food
queen song
they make the rock and world go around
uh no need to apologize we all like
different things
no one has to like everything oh good
that's a relief you look good tonight oh
anna thank you
i sneak just just for you uh
need another movie night yes that would
be that would be very cool
we'll try and not now
don't try and get planning out of me
right now
um yeah i'd love uh
i'd love it if you stayed on a live
stream all night but i really
need a piss i actually kind of do too so
like i am gonna wrap this up soon i'm
almost caught up though i swear
you are always bdsm buffy doctor who
star wars and more
nice i like it what are your thoughts on
say anything
i have not seen it a friend of mine even
gave me a copy as like a gift
i never got around to it have you seen
dominic noble's 50 shades review
you mean reviews plural because he did
three videos devoted to every single one
of those
books and movies yes i have and they're
amazing
so are folding ideas uh videos on them
both very good both worth watching
looking forward to
the dune 2020 trailer today is that
dropping today
uh guess i am now
uh let's see just say it once
uh not now chad mummy is hydrating
then take us
not now chet mommy's hydrating
there you go my cavity yes yes yeah yeah
we
we are gonna we are gonna wrap up soon
this is gone
this is gone very long
i remembered you looking up settle
unsettled when i brought up
the twilight zone movie accident last
time should john landis have been
punished more than he was for that
i don't know i don't know enough about
the circumstances to make that call
one way or the other i
i feel like the fact that the that even
though they didn't
they they never processed the film that
showed the death
i think the fact that that section of
the movie was even released is kind of
ghoulish
and i kind of wish they hadn't
uh okay i am almost caught up come on
come on come on you can't stand on the
live stream all the time you've got to
watch
doctor in distress and put in the break
room please
look calm yourself mama says miss you
here oh
thank you john night to momo 92 um
decay and night to you and night to
everyone i'm caught up
i caught up with questions i'm done
i am victorious don't post more stuff
attempt me to stay i gotta go so thank
you
everybody for tuning in thank you
actually you know what
i am going to do the foolish thing and
pop on to the
kickstarter and see where we sit right
now
so hold on
holy crap
holy crap um
oh my god it is um
it is less than 150 from hitting its
goal and it
it hasn't even been up for 12 hours
what the hell
oh
oh god damn it
oh yeah
wow
oh
well it um
not to count my chickens before they
hatched but
i think there's a very good shot at
hitting the um the goal i gotta
i gotta be prepared to lay out stretch
goals i think
uh
i tend to undercut in my head
the
level of support
that i have from people who i don't know
you know personally that i've never met
i my brain automatically
uh rounds that down
i think as a defense mechanism
and then every now and then
i get a reminder that um
people care and
like what i do and have faith in what i
want to
put out into the world and um
this is not the first time this has
happened
does that move when my first kickstarter
got funded this happened when
um the massive bump to my patreon
happened
after i was laid off
this is just the first time that is
happening
live
so and the fact that i've said that i've
had this reaction before
uh it's not it's not just the water
though that might be um amplifying it a
little bit
thank you
if you're backing the kickstarter thank
you if you are backing me on patreon
thank you if you are
just watching this in our financially
supporting me at all in any way
shape or form thank you
thank you
i'm a cynical person by nature
but i don't ignore
wonderful things when they happen
and all of you the supporters the
viewers the sharers
everybody you
give me so much hope
and so much strength and so much
joy you make it possible to do
what i do
and i never thought i'd have this
i really never did
thank you all so much
if you're watching this whether you're
watching it live whether you're playing
it back
if you're watching this if you're seeing
this at all
at any point ever
thank you
oh
it just jumped now it's okay i was
always 24
short of the goal oh my god
oh my god
oh
huh wow
you don't need to see me blubber anymore
thank you all and there are
super chats that i know happened while i
was
breaking down
good night looking forward to the book
thank you
thank you morgan thank you osma
thank you everyone who is here
and please
remember and i mean this from the bottom
of my heart
you are beautiful you are
valid you are loved
you are loved
you are the council you make this
possible
i just run the meetings
so until next time this council
is adjourned
thank you